use the quadratic formula to solve the
equation negative x squared plus 8x is
equal to 1. now in order to really use
the quadratic equation or to figure out
what our a's b's and c's are we have to
have our equation in the form a x
squared plus b x
plus c is equal to zero and then if we
know our a's b's and c's we'll say that
the solutions to this equation are x is
equal to
negative b plus or minus the square root
of b squared minus 4ac
all of that over 2a so the first thing
we have to do for this equation right
here is to put it in this form and on
one side of the equation we have a
negative x squared plus 8x so that looks
like the first two terms but our
constants on the other side so let's get
the constant out of the left-hand side
and get a 0 here on the right-hand side
so let's subtract
let's subtract 1 from both sides of this
equation the left hand side of the
equation will become negative x squared
plus 8 x
minus 1 and then the right hand side 1
minus 1 is 0. now we have it in that
form we have ax squared a is negative
one so let me write this down a is equal
to negative one
a is
right here a is equal to negative one
it's implicit there you could put a one
here if you like a negative 1 negative x
squared is the same thing as negative 1
x squared
b is equal to 8.
so b is equal to 8 that's the 8 right
there and c is equal to negative 1 and c
is equal to negative 1. that's the
negative 1 right there so now we can
just apply the quadratic formula the
solutions to this equation are x is
equal to negative b
so negative b
negative b
plus or minus
plus or minus the square root of b
squared
of eight squared
eight squared
minus four ac minus let me do that in
that green color
minus four the green is the part of the
formula the colored parts are the things
that we're substituting in the formula
minus four times a which is negative one
times negative 1 times c which is also
negative 1 times negative 1.
and then all of that let me extend the
square root sign a little bit further
all of that is going to be over 2 times
a in this case a is negative 1. so let's
simplify this
so this becomes negative 8 this is
negative 8 plus or minus the square root
of
8 squared is 64.
and then you have a negative 1 times a
negative 1 these just cancel out just to
be a 1. so 64 minus 4
that's just that 4 over there all of
that over negative 2. so this is equal
to negative 8 plus or minus the square
root of
60
all of that over negative 2.
let's see if we can simplify
the the expression the radical
expression here the square root of 60.
let's see 60
is equal to two times thirty thirty is
equal to two times
fifteen
and then fifteen is three times five so
we do have a perfect square here we do
have a two times two in there it is two
times two times fifteen or four times 15
so we could write the square root of 60
is equal to the square root of 4 times
the square root of 15 right square root
of 4
times the square root of 15 that's what
60 is 4 times 15 and so this is equal to
square root of 4 is 2
times the square root of 15. so we can
rewrite this expression right here as
being equal to
negative 8 plus or minus
plus or minus 2
times the square root
2 times the square root
of 15 all of that over negative 2.
now we can divide both of both of these
terms right here are divisible by either
two or negative two so let's divide it
so we have negative eight divided by
negative two which is positive four so
let me write it over here negative eight
divided by negative two
is positive four and then you have this
weird thing plus or minus two divided by
negative two and really what we have
here is two expressions but if we're
plus two and we divide by negative two
it will be negative one and if we take
negative two and divide by negative two
we're gonna have positive one so instead
of plus or minus you could imagine it is
going to be you could imagine it now as
being
minus or plus but it's really the same
thing right it's really now minus or
plus if it was plus it's not going to be
a minus now it's a minus it's not going
to be a plus minus or plus
2 times the square root
2
times the square root of 15. or another
way to view it is that the two solutions
here are 4 minus 2 roots of 15
and 4 plus 2
roots of 15. these are both
values of x that will satisfy this
equation and if this confused you what i
did turning in a plus or minus into
minus plus let me just take a little bit
of a side there i could write this
expression up here i could write this
expression as two expressions that's
what the plus or minus really is there's
a negative 8 plus the square let me
there's a negative 8 plus
2 roots of 15 over negative 2 and then
there's a negative 8 minus 2 roots
15
over negative 2. this one simplifies to
negative 8 divided by negative 2 is 4
2
divided by negative 2 is negative 1
2
times this 4 minus square root of 15 and
then over here you have negative 8
divided by negative 2 which is 4 and
then negative 2 divided by negative 2
which is plus the square root of 15. and
i just realized i made a mistake up here
when we're dividing it 2 divided by
negative 2 we don't have this 2 over
here
this is just a
plus or minus the root of 15. we just
saw that when i did it out here so this
is minus the square root of 15 and this
is plus the square root of 15. so the
two solutions for this equation it's
good that i took that little hiatus
there that little aside there the two
solutions x could be 4 minus the square
root of 15 or x or and x could be 4 plus
the square root of 15. either of those
values of x will satisfy
will satisfy this original quadratic
equation